[Music]
he has to remember to kind of keep uh
close relationships but not fully
disclose who he is and while that's very
protective and probably for the best
it's not good for his mental
health my name is Dr Drea lendi and I'm
a licensed clinical
psychologist both Spider-Man and Batman
experienced a devastating loss when they
were kids losing a primary caregiver is
considered such a big traumatic event
for kids especially the trauma though is
really the interpretation of the event
trauma is not only the distressing event
it's the emotional processing of what
happens during that event and it's so
individualized to each person so whereas
Batman maybe felt a sense of L loss of
control a strong burden to take care of
not only himself but the city even the
world after that event Peter Parker has
more of a positive developmental growth
coming out of his trauma this is called
post-traumatic growth where he starts to
of course he's going through all of the
normal grieving process after losing
Uncle Ben but he's also starting to
realize his own sense of self-efficacy
and agency and some sense of
responsibility for his own person so his
expectations are not excessive they're
not
narcissistic they're not unrealistic he
believes that as an individual he could
do more he could really make a
difference in the city we see Peter
Parker on such a more accelerated
recovery because of his willingness to
seek social support his willingness to
see a realistic version of himself and
the world and to let this tragedy give
him a sense of Positive Purpose versus a
vindictive
[Music]
goal what happened to Peter Parker was
not his choice he was essentially
transformed violated disfigured you
could think of all different ways in
which he might interpret this big change
in his life also as a young person
you're already going through a lot of
social emotional and um personality
changes that we can think of this
transformation is happening in some kind
of alignment or co-occurrence with his
own personal individual development and
so a lot of things are going to feel out
of whack a lot of things are going to
feel like almost dis orienting maybe he
feels he's outside of his body maybe he
feels like he's looking at his own hand
or his own Limbs and feel like that's
not mine that's not my hand that's not
my limb and it's going to take time for
him to start to associate the abilities
that he has and also some of the
disfigurements if you will um some of
the unexpected changes in his body to be
fully a part of him in some ways if I
were his therapist I'd work on grieving
the old Peter Parker what did he miss or
what does he miss about the non
Spider-Man Peter Parker is it the
innocence is it that his body was um not
changed is it that he didn't feel this
extra sense of burden and to work
through some appropriate level of
grieving his previous body and
understanding how his new body is in
alignment with who he is as a person he
can still hold the same value and
principles he can still feel that
fundamentally he's the same person but
he does have to work on integrating
these new changes even if there're ones
that he doesn't like into his sense of
self his repertoire tell
[Music]
ho there's a therapeutic technique for
getting over our fears and it's called
exposure therapy it's basically where a
counselor works with an individual who
has an anxiety disorder or a phobia
and gradually exposes them to that
feared stimulus in this case if we're
thinking of tall buildings and leaping
from building to building in it of
itself of course that could be very
dangerous but if we know fundamentally
that Peter is equipped to do this kind
of thing he has all of the abilities to
manage this it's really about overcoming
the fear of heights the fear of falling
whatever it might be that's troubling
him my Uncle Ben was
killed
it was my
fault I lost Gwen my
um she was my
MJ I think it could have been
disconcerning for some of us to see
multiple Spider-Mans and to notice that
all of them have their unique losses and
histories and they're coming together
and it's a bit of a violation right to
talk about or or even hint at their own
experiences and histories there is
something therapeutic though to
interacting with other selves in the
Multiverse the idea that had you taken
one path or gone a different way your
life could be completely different than
what it is now and we actually do that a
lot psychologically we may not know that
we're doing this but we often think
about what could have happened or what
could be based on the decisions that
we're making it's called counterfactual
thinking it's when there's a critical
event maybe something really meaningful
something significant maybe even a
trauma that we go through and our brains
kind of take us through different
Pathways of gosh what would have
happened had I not you know left the
house at that time or what would have
happened if I uh took responsibility and
did something differently and a lot of
times all of those ruminations while
they're very normal they can create a
sense of sadness confusion a lot of
curiosity about what could be and in
small doses it can be really healthy for
us considering how important our agency
is how important the experiences that we
have can be to toward our
personhood but it can also be unhealthy
and to name another superhero or super
villain W maximoff is an example of
someone who took that counterfactual
thinking and just created this whole
world of what she would have liked her
life to be it's an ultra fantasy
so when we get too stuck in our
alternate versions of ourselves we could
lose a sense of actual control we could
lose a sense of who we are today now in
this moment and anything we can do to
ground ourselves back to take that
lesson maybe that Peter Parker learned
when interacting with his other selves
and realized that could be informative
for him that could be a moment of
discover y it could be a moment of
feeling relief and even a sense of uh
empowerment for his
opportunities can I come
in no this is a burden that a lot of
superheroes have to face it's the
duality of your identities it's knowing
that the more and more people you let
into your whole life the more and more
people people you inform about your
superhero altar the more that they might
be at risk and fundamentally that is
probably I'd say the scariest thing for
superheroes especially for Spider-Man
who knows what it's like to lose so that
guardedness is really important for him
he has to remember to kind of keep a
close relationships but not fully
disclose who he is not fully be open and
authentic
with everybody in his life and while
that's very protective and probably for
the best it's not good for his mental
health when we're not authentic we're
not showing our full sides we're not
fully whole when we interact with people
close to us we over time can start to
feel detached we could have low
self-esteem we could feel even a sense
of identity crisis you know does anyone
really know who I am and what I'm about
and I can't share the things that are
really critical in my life
and not only can I not share them I
can't feel a sense of closeness with
people in the way that I might want to
feel so there's a lot of different
occupational hazards when it relates to
superheroes who have dual identities
spider Menace governments around the
world launch investigations into the
murderer known as Spider-Man whether
you're a villain or not anytime you have
a fixation on a person who represents
your grievance that is a bad pathway in
other words that fixation that
narrow-mindedness that sense of
vindictiveness those traits over time
can be really destructive especially if
that figure that you're blaming that
figure that represents all of your sense
of anger and hatred is present that you
see that person they're within your
sights they're alive they're present
that could just perpetuate that sense of
uh vindictive narcissism and I add
narcissism because it's the idea that
you are somehow in this relationship
with that person even though they may
not feel the same way you've almost
exaggerated a sense of importance about
yourself and the interesting thing is a
lot of times when these villains feel
this immense sense of needing
retribution and looking for some sense
of conviction or some sense of recovery
a lot of times the hero isn't even
paying attention to them and that can be
absolutely dissatisfying and upsetting
so it kind of creates this cycle and of
course it ends in destruction the fact
that Spider-Man is kind of flippant and
has a light-hearted sense of humor and
personality may even drive these factors
um to become more and more excessive and
extreme think about wanting someone to
pay attention to you wanting someone to
take you seriously wanting them to fully
hear your grievance and why you're so
upset and the other person is
light-hearted dismissive doesn't really
see you eye to eye isn't even willing to
give you the time of day so are you like
a cow or a Dalmatian I am the
spot that unbalance um can be
particularly unsatisfying but it could
also just ramp up these negative
feelings and and create a really
dangerous uh situation dangerous
relationships between Peter Parker and
the villains that um that oppose him
night
night you look
nice Peter Parker is still growing up
and he's experiencing impostor syndrome
probably more days than not meaning that
even though he has these amazing
abilities he's super intelligent he's um
socially quite capable he has a lot of
amazing qualities and yet he feels
unsure of himself he has some
self-doubts some of this is due to
Simply his developmental phase like
where he is in his life some of it is
due to personal loss and knowing that he
hasn't been perfect he's made mistakes
he has been responsible for some serious
things and a part of it is also when he
is Spider-Man he may feel like that
version of himself might be more in
alignment with who he truly is so when
he can't integrate Peter Parker and
Spider-Man and he's sort of feeling
vulnerable he may show elements of that
sense of self-doubt that sense of um uh
ineffectiveness a sense of having to
question his
[Music]
actions